the first thing and this may be the most  important thing and the most overlooked  thing ever i have not used an alarm to  wake up in over a decade so  you've got to remember your brain needs  a certain amount of sleep and if you  don't get that amount of sleep you can  actually test the cognitive decline so  step number one is really treating sleep  like one of the most important things  you're going to do you want to get to  bed early so that you don't have to be  pressured to set an alarm to make it to  work on time or whatever the case may be  so if you've got to go to bed at 8 00 pm  go to bed at 8 pm i know how terrifying  that sounds to you but i'm gonna have to  be honest if you're not prepared to  prioritize sleep then you're not  prepared to do the things you need to do  to be successful